so guess what's happening our buddy
Isaiah Factory by the way no one covers
success except for us now
is uh I I I was scrolling through
Twitter like not even people I'm
following just somebody saw the title
yeah yeah but this was a clip now this
is going this this clip you're about to
play is going viral on Twitter so the
regular people have found the normies
have found Isaiah which was our little
hidden treasure you know Isaiah and I
was wondering why I saw of all people
today Red Ice tweeted a video of Isaiah
and I was like like Henrik from red eyes
and I was like
okay what's going on here that's our
look we've been everyone watched the
show knows
Isaiah's been our little slice of
Houston okay
and well I saw the clip on Twitter and
I'm like no no I'm not gonna do I'm not
gonna deal with this 90 second clip I
went and found the whole video
yes it's it's a good it's as good as you
think welcome back to the factor
uncensored when my producer sent me this
topic I had to stop my lunch
I just couldn't eat anymore it's a male
hygiene problem or issue called Gooch
Greece
haha
I was like what the hell is that you
probably said what the [__] is that [__]
is what you really said Isaiah yeah I I
heard what happened when you get a bug
in your mouth yeah killing it I was
bothered
we know Isaiah was a meme Legend from
the bug clip we played it on the show
but he disappeared since then and he has
his own show on Fox 26 and trust me I'm
looking at his views we were the only
ones covering him victimized how long is
this
uh six minutes this is going to be a six
minute wash your ass segment yes let
astray it described it's described as a
culmination of Lent sweat and dried up
pieces of feces between a man's butt and
my butt is not like that I want to be
clear I clean my ass
I mean look I've had a
I've had some times where I just like
you know what I mean we worked out and
then you kind of came home you didn't
shower right away and you're like
[__] off on the computer for a little
bit and then like you know whatever you
might do some dishes why and then you
might take a shower like a couple hours
later and yeah at that point you're kind
of like okay you got some funk but like
even then what is Gooch grease like I've
had some you know some some old ball
cheese and stuff when you've been
running around all day running error you
get home you're like oh you get a
showering and you're like okay I'm
pretty gross right but
pieces of fecal matter are mixed with
lint like how [__] filthy are you I
mean I mean fecal matter get wipes you
know wet wipe game you know what they
say baby the duck or the butthole the
sweet of the juice I mean that sounds
great but I have one of those fancy
Japanese do you have the [__]
pressure washer but I'm talking about
for normal people that don't have a
[__] fancy toilet that they brag
about just get wipes
take get listen do yourself a favor
because we both do the same thing right
I got we both got our home wipes yeah
and then you got the mini thing of wipes
and you take those with you on the right
I got Road wipes I got Road wipes like
this I got roadways I ain't even got
Gooch grease on a [__] 16 hour car
ride because when I stop off it's
getting we wiping down bro like you get
a little mint smell eat the mint ones
remember I like the mint ones with the
scene of American Dad when Roger's like
well now I have to go so I can how do I
put this wipe better
oh yeah read the screen
uh Samurai cicada is definitely not the
drug money Wink in exchange for
entertainment in laughs wink wink
awkwardly hands out a crumbled five
dollar bill thank you sir hey hit the
like button too please everyone with the
like buttons
first of all who are these men but he's
not having this [__] Isaiah's not having
this because you know Isaiah is one of
those guys that probably puts baby
powder on his ass he's clean yeah he's
one of those black guys his elbows are
not ashy man I don't even go another 12
hours without putting a little powder on
my ass problem is so bad for some men
According to some reports they now have
to use Women's maxi pads why is that
problem so bad if you wipe your ass okay
and keep yourself sanitary that's not
gonna happen
yeah and let me help you out compression
underwear men what are you doing live in
that mini Andy ditch life just stop the
mix what about the compression underwear
so if you wear that compression
underwear when Florida when it's hot and
stuff like that the the liquid I'm
wearing them right now yeah yeah yeah
exactly that that's exactly my point the
liquid Wicks away instead of like if
it's so if it's cotton underwear it
soaks in the cotton oh yeah is that what
I'm saying well that's why I feel like a
sauna that's why you have to have them
if you're gonna go walking and running
like exactly I have like six pairs of
[__] compression shorts because when
I if I do like because I walk to the
store now just to get exercise if I walk
the storm back like he said regular
boxers on I'm chafed amount right
because the cotton like absorbs all the
sweat and it becomes like if you grow
potatoes in there it becomes [__]
like a sauna like a [__] like a
greenhouse but compression otherwise it
Wicks away but messing up their
underwear one of the right is yellow
well there's Gooch grease on it
it's a mixture now let's get into this
Jim we don't have to I mean you did a
six and you did a seven minute segment
on this Isaiah I mean come on man
Memorial Day weekend man it was slow no
it wasn't a lot of your people were out
doing a lot of bad stuff you're gonna
cover that honestly to be fair to him he
does actually no I know he does his
action I just looked at his Twitter and
he did uh his last tweet was like 19
hours ago and uh he literally he's doing
his uh like his Fitbit like mapping yes
and it's like literally just a straight
Square block around his building he
works at that's awesome and he wrote
nice bike ride near the job tonight
they're shooting and stabbing people on
bikes everywhere else
we will address it Thursday night on the
Isaiah factors I like him but it's
definitely but I like that he's bougie
enough he's like all right I do my bike
rides ride around the goddamn around the
fox doing the 30 laps around his
building while the doorman watches okay
let's see what Killer's row he has
anyway I can say the other one if I
wanted to too LT kg smooth and comedian
and sports journalist Barry laminate
so Barry have you I as you know why are
you laughing Barry we haven't started
yet I just I don't know what to do
man I see us always stressed to the
knives I give him credit man he really
is always dressed like to the nines
that's why I made the joke about the
baby powder yeah yeah yeah when you
walked in you dropped this oh you didn't
understand when Barry's grandfather was
on his deathbed he looked at Barry took
his hand and he went Barry one day I
need you to go on Fox and talk about
ass sweat and there he is and which to
calm down I'm sick of this white guy
yeah he's really bugging me
you did a good job ew you're doing like
Middle School humor yeah all day
oh my God you see this guy's like one of
those like trying to oh my God like one
of those like facial like humor oh yeah
have you ever heard of this you know
what I mean Costello over here is both
of them is he is this guy gonna talk
like a wigger hold on what's going on
it's MC search
not really I haven't heard of it by that
name but there's some foul dudes out
there
he's yeah probably Jewish wigger that's
why I said MC search is that MC search
Five like it's kind of disgusting hey
Maurice I have a question
the girl to the right of him though what
are we thinking
uh what are we thinking what are we
thinking here
not not Trump got marched each other
green on the right but orange retailer
green yeah I will say this man is
acceptable within three words of her
Marjorie Taylor Vetter day very day yes
yes get older you get bigger see I don't
have to
worry about it that dude that dude looks
like and correct me if I'm wrong here he
looks like he got that little micro
tattoo thing done to fill his hair out
look look at how even the line is yeah
hold on guys I'm gonna go to his
Instagram I am Barry is funny he is not
oh he's not even there
I found him
really I found his insta
mine's saying sorry this page is not
available right here this guy right he
just already blocked you yeah I'm like
what the no now it loaded okay what the
[__] that I wasn't even logged in
that would have been funny though right
what
was he is is he funny guy isn't he funny
I don't say anything about him on his
Instagram comedy yeah I gotta find it
Jim
I learned that just because as you have
your headphones in and can't hear
yourself fart
let's learn that
that doesn't mean it didn't happen sir
a lot of [__] Hamming it up hold your
feet for sit-ups after that yes
did you notice he's doing a completely
different voice than he's doing with
Isaiah of course the wigger voice is
gone and now the effeminate Jewish Voice
is coming out
he comes from a long line of shape
shifters oh yeah I guess you're right
let's hear him here this but as you get
older you get bigger you sweat more
that's a different voice if this is a
problem for you fellas you don't you
don't need that I feel I'm ready to put
his Ghetto Boy shirt on he sees Ghetto
Boys I can't miss him
to the black chick I want to see what
she's about
any powder but what about the little
dingleberries
okay okay
we need to normalize the days amen
sister a [__] men sister
so I clean my ass clean that's a common
courtesy that's a good girl and one of
the only countries where it's just not a
thing you're just wiping your butt with
just raw tissue and that's it yeah
nothing moist yo [__] get the toilet
you give me poor people get just the
toilet top seats if you want oh yeah but
that's not it thank you so on Twitter I
have and I'm like I'm supposed to follow
I'm on Twitter so all the topics that
come on the news everything I see all of
it I was not but I just prefer a TV baby
girl no no she shouldn't have done that
skipped over because I'm like oh I don't
have one would you be bothered by a guy
that you you date and then you realize
okay he you guys are about to have
relations
bro he always brings it back to sex I
love his Isaiah he's a horny man hands
down and then there is are you about to
go down on a man's ass and he nasty
let's keep going
you'll see the pad when I see the Gucci
on his booty yes
number one your pad is not even clean
okay let's get it started right there
now so I like her you know what I like
her I saw the pattern in the underwear
I'd say feminine products on the box for
a reason ma'am who are you a grizzled
bartender the Coyote Ugly yeah dude
she looks she looks like she works at a
tiki bar on the weekdays like on a tiki
bar Madeira Beach she calls you sugar
yeah
underwear at night time you need to be
ashamed they need to be ashamed
I actually like the black
Pharrell oh Pharrell yeah they have to
do it is this a homophobia yeah the girl
on the right looks like somebody who
occasionally has to bring her kid to her
bartending job yes oh my God babysitter
and they all know and they all know no
no no the kid on the right you mean the
woman on the right one on the right her
grandkid to her bartending job
biracial grandkid named Aiden to her
bartending job and they know him and
what they do is they they give him a cup
and like they give them like soda and
they let them play with straws
that ain't good enough that's very
specific but I think we all seen that
right now we've all seen A variation
we've all seen A variation of that
yeah you know what I do not hate his
biggie shirt I'll be honest with you
it's actually pretty dope shirt I want
one that's a pretty dog yeah I don't
even mind the Ghetto Boys shirt just a
juice liquor
don't get me wrong I am I'm a proud
member or maybe the captain I'll take
one uh venti Pharrell uh but do you guys
have a dark roast a venti a dark roast I
like it the Commando Club but because it
gets hot here in Houston commando's
terrible Commandos are alive Commandos
worse trust me command we're in Florida
man try we get like the humidity and the
swamp crotch it's the worst if you want
everyone to smell your funk then go
commando do not go commando compression
underwear if you're gonna sweat get
compressed I cannot tell you guys it'll
save your [__] life
New Balance makes really good ones and
and Adidas makes really good ones also
hear me out based on the complaint that
they're having about it being like this
Gooch grease whatever how about just a
daily shower just one now I feel like we
just keep all of that under control and
if you work out a lot like when I was
working out a lot sure there was that
second shower where you come home and
you're like all right I get all this
[__] [__] off I don't like going to
bed when you're dirty yeah that's what I
mean but like you know and then but then
the next day I might get up and be like
I still want to take another shower I
waste a lot of water I don't give a [__]
about the environment
[__] environment bro sometimes I just
get in the shower just because I like
being in a shower yeah sometimes I get a
headache I'm like I'll take a hot shower
it feels good and stop telling me I'm
wasting water I'm not wasting water
because when I'm done showering I mean
if the water's still there well I mean
ice it still exists it's somewhere yeah
okay got it yeah
you gotta wear underwear in my jeans
though man like come on man you just
went wrong like that's a good point
third freaking monkey or are there
people not taking a shower yes there are
people that I know that do not shower
every day honestly and they're
disgusting
yeah
all right step go ahead there's a
shortage actually for tampons and and
pads I have no re I have no idea why
because trans people are buying them now
as a fashion statement yeah that's
probably not helping so it's probably
about it's great for the companies yeah
and that's at home man like you got a
close-up oh boy
oh boy she's rough oh boy how you doing
I swear
I'm like no
like the shelves are bare of it she will
blow you behind a Buffalo Wild Wings
she'll blow you in a buffalo
during a playoff game
while you're eating
yes right there at the bar then you can
wipe your hands on her hair
and she doesn't care
don't need to be wearing that I mean
literally she has the voice I would have
expected to yeah she's on point yeah
that's better or someone said make your
work transition then something you work
go to the doctor if you've got some
issue or whatever by the way voice I
would expect an anthropomorphized
Percocet pill to have
Warden Gordon's calling her Greg the
hammer Linda Hogan oh my God yes Greg
the hammer Linda Hogan's great
everybody
that's it no Commando in Florida I have
to use freaking baby powder it's so
humid in Florida especially if you're no
[__] and shave your hair they're like
what do they mean better front to back
you shave your hair ill
yeah we know that you wipe away from
your balls I don't [__] get it like
what's the issue here
or you get fancy and you one hand you
lift your balls and then you wipe
who's wiping towards their balls I don't
know I don't know it doesn't even feel
natural like that like wiping up to down
feels very unnatural right you're not a
real man unless you have a skid mark
under your nut sack that's a good point
what is that
[__] your balls look like a [__]
18-wheeler lost control last night yo
that's like one of them
yeah
looks like the [__] scene of Paul
Walker's crash [__] Ryan Dunn yeah
remember those [__] tire marks boy
did he try to stop that that
[__] tried to stop for a quarter
mile half leader of the room says
learning much about learning uh so much
about balls today we could teach you
more if you want we can tell you
everything balls are [__] annoying
when it gets hot women did you know this
your ball sometimes sticks to the side
of your legs and it's [__] the worst
ask you why you just flicked your leg
yes exactly or men have to do the shake
like the leg shake or sometimes just go
in there I pull it I grab it all you do
that [__] steel base move yeah will
you do that long like [__] where you
just take a side step when you're
walking yeah yeah you do that looks like
you're [__] stealing second base
I aggressively flick my leg
well no I'm 40 now I just correct I just
grab my balls and pull them off my leg
Yeah I don't care anymore like that's
something so freeing about like being at
this level where you're like you know
what helps that too compression
underwear let's go back to those again
it helps your balls not get stuck to
your leg it's still happening I said
less yeah I was gonna say the problem is
you got to make sure they're [__] on
tight and pulled up yeah yeah yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
um Mr foot big just said sticky bubble
gum do you ever do this move do you ever
do this move
hand in the pocket grab the balls and
lift them yeah they're the right Pockets
you can do that I've done that but I
it's not my favorite move because it's
even weirder than just grabbing at the
gym I walk up to women that are using
the lead Chrome machine and I put right
in their face and put my hands where I
go ah and I go you know what I did you
know what I did and I walk away I'm no
longer allowed at curves so which is
and everywhere we go there's [__]
like middle-aged fat women giving them
weird looks it's super weird yeah adults
hour on Gooch grease I don't give a [__]
we got more out of this than you did
Isaiah thank you Isaiah for this this is
great thank you so much not too much you
two you look like LeBron James coming in
man why you talking like this dog like
why are you still doing this man no no
this is what he really sounds like James
every one of the witches like treadmill
Moses I walk up it's just Parts
everybody just get along I think he I
think he is a bit of a wigger
like because I can hear it a little bit
here too but it definitely comes out
more when he's around black people
they're calling me Royce the adjuster
Lopez I like that
it's a cool like John Wick title except
it's me aggressively grabbing my balls
in front of MILFs